for some reason or another unetbootin
doesn't seem to have succeeded in
correctly writing the operating system
to this disk so we're going try again
over here and each quickly open up some
things I'll comment the commands of Tom
and unetbootin didn't work some reason
but that's kind of convenient because I
gets the opportunity to show how to this
process from Linux situations from
Bunter which is what we're going to
school today has the Linux kernel and
then for the window for the graphics
manager for what you interact with you
have what's called unity and then for a
package manager which is how you
download your software essentially like
a kind of more basic app store you have
aptitude so that's kind of the three
main components of a Linux operating
system nowadays anyway you have the
kernel the window manager and your
package manager those are the primary
components at differentiate a pack a
distribution for the end user those are
the ones that people typically choose
their distribution on there's various
other bits that can be changed and
there's lots that can be tweaked enough
in a distribution but those are the
primary concerns you might use to have
Windows you want a new piece of software
you want to put a program to open a
certain file you have to go troll in
Google find download link download it
and install it
whereas package managers will kind of
app stores before app stores existed
you just open a package manager find
what you want one-click installation it
downloads the perfect one for your
machine don't worry about choosing the
right download don't program viruses
it's all verified and you get your
software so we're going to use this dish
using a key model and utility called DD
which will let us extract the I
socialist disk and hopefully have some
success I don't know the points of my
head so I'm go to copy/paste in this
page so it's really easy to get the
commands to do this and lots we've done
for for lots of available licenses from
the inventor forum at burn an ISO to USB
device the DD command requires two
parameters and so we need to have the
ISO which were writing to it and we need
to have the mount point of the device so
the mount point is the directory in the
filesystem earth devices mounted so it's
quite a arcane looking piece of
information and it's quite difficult to
find additional commands but we can use
gparted which is a graphical user
interface application to really easily
find that so we can see here that it's
four slash dev fourths
F for / s DB so we'll whack that in and
we've already got the ISO in there so
now if I do that according to my past I
think I run the command without any
output so I'm now just going to sit here
and wait hope that's working the DD
command unless you give it the option to
do so doesn't the spiny Diagnostics and
I didn't give it that command
so I'm now sitting here hoping and
praying that it is actually in fact
doing what it should be doing we've
written the DD with the stick
and I've just check to see if it's
working so better plugged it in change
the blue option to USB and your IDs
sorry on so on this machine so not on
our dictum and plugged in change the
built-in USB and it went free to boot
fine boot up into a bun T and when it
first boots it presents you an option if
you want to try bun - so run extra off
the stick or whether you want to install
it and so now we're going to have the
moment of truth and try it on the
patient